hey youtubers it's Charlie my spidey
sense is tingling so we learned about
some other avengers that might be popping
up in spider-man homecoming like his
friend from Brooklyn and we learned
about when the first trailer might be
dropping so here we go
so we all know that Robert Downey jr.
has been confirmed for spider-man
homecoming you know he's gonna be used
in a small way but important i'm not
expecting him to have as much time on
screen as they like spider-man had
during civil war like it's gonna be a
spider-man movie so it's mostly going to
be spider-man interacting with those
characters Avengers will just became
cameoing but it makes sense that they would
follow up on the energy of that like
spider-man interaction with Captain
America during civil war where he comes
into the fight as Iron Man's new ringer
but he's also this huge fan and looks up
to captain america
hey cap big fan so would make sense that
you know if they're not going to do the
uncle ben origin story that they would
still maintain the great power great
responsibility subtext of the spider-man
character just passed that on to Iron
Man Captain America the real question
though is because Captain America is now
off the gritty still a fugitive from the
government so he has to stay on the DL
but i think the end tag for civil war
was a sign that the the really bad blood
like that i want to shoot you in the
face bad blood between captain america
iron met is largely gone but I'm not
expecting a scene where they interact
together onscreen I'm just expecting
scenes where spider-man interacts with
iron man and then separately in other
scenes he interacts with Captain America
but in that there will be some
connective tissue to the stuff that
happened with all those characters in
civil war now remember captain america
left the shield behind he's not Captain
America anymore so I don't think that
spider-man is going to give him his
shield back even though that happened
during civil war in the comics that's
just because the Russos have said that
when Avengers infinity war picks back up
he won't be the captain america
character he'll just be Steve Rogers
like the captain america name is dead
for all intensive purposes it's like
it's sitting on a shelf somewhere
waiting for someone to pick it up for
Steve Rogers to pick it back up but
because they're kind of like the moral
conscience of spider-man right now like
he looks up to them so they're meant to
be these big role models even though
they took a few knocks during civil war
like morally they were on shaky ground
for a little bit of it like Steve Rogers
not letting Tony Stark know that
winter soldier killed his parents even
though he knew beforehand but even
though each of them kind of giving
spider-man some advice like being the
big brother or the father figure that he
doesn't have right now is a really cool
idea i do expect them to have like some
cool moment they'll be the all moment
like all that's gonna really awesome
speech they gave to him that they gave
him some help in making some big
decisions that he needed to make but
they'll also probably be oh my god
that's cool moment like the thing with
Tony Stark is that he always has the
best toys the captain america has all
the amazing moves but just expect
spider-man to have a little bit of fun
with his friends from Brooklyn like he
told Aunt May always your friend from
all he's from Brooklyn you know many guy
he's from Brooklyn and his other friend
Tony Stark who ought may already knows
about but the other room now is the
Black Widow will also have a small role
in the film so wouldn't it be fun if
they use those three Avengers characters
is a form of spider-man's in super-ego
and ego so Freudian psychology the it is
kind of like Tony Stark the instinctual
part of your brain that acts on impulse
the super-ego is the moralizing part of
your brain
the captain america part the part of
your brain that's always telling you to
do what's morally right in each
situation and then the ego is kind of
like the Black Widow the thing that
mediates between the desires of the it'd
in the super-ego so you have iron man
who just is very impulsive you have
Captain America that's always taking the
moral high ground then you have black
widow who tries to like mediate between
the two of them like dudes do not fight
let's be reasonable about this
so maybe they'll end up using those
characters in the spider-man movie in
that way like spider-man has a lot of
problems that he faces he has things
that he wants to do he has things that
he knows he should probably do need to
find some sort of compromise between
them
let me know in the comments how do you
think they would use captain america in
Black Widow in a spider-man movie now we
kind of know Ironman is giving him
technology like on a very simple level
he just giving him some upgrades giving
him a little bit of advice maybe some
help with the big villain with the
vulture in the film but on a much deeper
subtextual level I think they'll feel
like the ego super-ego in the great
power great responsibility theme to the
spider-man character but you know very
important for the spider-man character
but since they're not going to do the
Uncle Ben origin story
they're not literally going to do that
scene again so they have to weave it
into the subtext of the film but for
those you asking there is a rumor that a
spider-man trailer is going to drop in
the middle of $MONTH october it's
unconfirmed but supposedly there was
like a leak that listed like when a
bunch of trailers were going to be
released
there was a spider-man trailer listed
smack-dab in the middle of $MONTH
october so just be prepared for your
spidey sense to start tingling if you
guys didn't know there is a new round of
the giveaway that's going on now the
Civil War blu rays coming out on Friday
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video is just for the value of the
blu-ray so it's about a thirty-dollar
amazon gift card to get hype they just
announced a really big cast member Jim
Broadbent is joining Game of Thrones
Season seven I have a couple theories
about what think he's going to be so
i'll be doing a video for that later
tonight also still want to do that
Justice League Deathstroke follow video
Joe Manganiello is rumored to be playing
Deathstroke but it's unconfirmed there a
couple other big actors that I think
could pull it off
so try to get that stuff out as fast as
possible while you guys wait for that
supposed you can click here to watch the
Civil War bloopers again you can click
here for spider-man homecoming
behind-the-scenes thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight!